let's go the country's top wrestlers are
back at this protest site in the heart
of New Delhi they say the president of
the Federation and other coaches have
been harassing women for years they're
also alleging corruption and
ill-treatment of athletes at National
camps
though not at all there are coaches in
the National camps who are favorites of
the Wrestling Federation of India and
they sexually assault wrestlers and
misbehave with women coaches they have
again been employed at the national camp
in spite of my raising my voice against
them the federation's president is a
member of Parliament and the governing
bharti janta party he's refuting the
allegations
these are not Petty charges that I can't
just let go of an investigation should
definitely be done but only time will
tell who will conduct it
protesters include some of India's most
decorated athletes wrestling is one of
the few Sports where Indian women have
won medals including the Olympics they
say they're raising their voice for all
female wrestlers in India wrestling is
popular in rural India many athletes
come from regions where patriarchal
Norms dominate child marriage enforced
abortion of female fetuses is common but
in the past decade women wrestlers have
broken barriers to build International
sporting careers
protesters say sexism is rampant in
Indian Sports where there are few women
in leadership roles
a lot of girls see their future in
sports they have all come from
marginalized poor families and we take
Sports as a measure of mobility and if
they are subjected to this kind of
harassment how can we keep quiet that's
why we have come forward to support them
the government has asked the Federation
to respond to these allegations a
national coaching Camp has also been
canceled these athletes are determined
to have their voices heard and say they
will keep protesting till authorities
take action against the Federation Chief
Al Jazeera New Delhi